my name is J apt I'm the director of the
Carnegie Mellon electricity industry
Center a joint project of The Temper
School of Business in the engineering
and public policy department we actually
have people from seven different
departments at Carnegie Mellon about 15
active faculty about two dozen active
PhD students it's the largest
interdisciplinary Center in the world
studying the problems of the electric
power industry and let me tell you there
are really exciting problems when I was
a kid we are using we used 1/8 the
electric power that we use now even
though the population is only up by a
factor of 2 the use of electric power is
up by a factor of 8 it's just amazing
you can see here how it is grown in the
time since 1950 it shows no sign at all
of slacking off and so where do we get
our electric power from in this country
we get it about half from coal about 25%
from natural gas about 20% from nuclear
power and a smattering of a few other
things mostly hydroelectric power when
we talk about the future of clean energy
in this country we generally mean clean
electricity and the way that we're going
to get that most people presume is from
renewable energy so what is our
renewable energy coming from today at
the moment we have about 2/3 of the
renewable energy coming from
hydroelectric power about 1/4 of it
comes from wind now wind is the fastest
growing piece of all of our renewable
energy most people when they say how you
solve the electricity problem they think
about solar energy indeed there's 4,000
times as much sunlight falls on the
United States as we need but the problem
is it's terribly expensive and so
they're those tiny sliver of our power
that is put out by sunlight so let's
concentrate on win well we've spent a
fair amount of time doing research in
the mathematics of wind power when power
is the fastest-growing of all of our
energy sources but it's variable just
like hydroelectric power
this slide shows the variation since
1970 of hydroelectric power in the
United States it's up and down by 20 to
40 percent
well what about wind wind it turns out
on small time skills is even more
variable than water power this is a
picture of all of the wind turbines in
the great state of Texas
it's the largest concentration of wind
anywhere in the United States of America
and as you can see it was up and down
and up and down on all timescales so we
started examining the mathematical
character of that it's not white noise
it's not the same amount of power at all
frequencies it turns out that's really
good because if it was white noise we
needed as many fast ramping sources
really expensive ones as we do slow
ramping sources to buffer the wind power
because of what we found we now know
that we can integrate wind power into
the system by using slow ramping fossil
fuel plants as well as really
ultra-modern things like superconducting
magnetic energy storage we just don't
need so much of that that's a really
good thing so we asked some different
questions about when we asked over the
time of a few years do we have droughts
in the wind like we have droughts in the
water power and the answer when we
looked at it is yes there's gonna be
windy years and not so windy years so we
have to take that into account just like
we do for a hydroelectric power and then
we said well you know you put a lot of
wind in and you put a lot of reliance on
your wind what are the chances that the
wind is just going to die you have a big
high-pressure area come over you and
kill all the wind for a while well if
you look at the state of Oregon up in
the Pacific Northwest of the US we found
that in January a few years ago there
were two weeks with no wind power at all
what you see in the slide is the falling
off of the wind so that it didn't
generate a thing so no matter how much
wind power you put in the system you're
gonna have to put quite a lot of other
energy in the system in order to
well now let's turn to solar power you
look outside on a sunny day in Arizona
and you think well gee whiz the Sun is
just beating down solar-powered lease
during the daytime has to be completely
a wonderful source of power it's got to
be constant no problems so we looked at
two years of data from the largest solar
plant in the country at the time and
what we found was that on some days
indeed the sunlight goes up as the Sun
reaches noon it starts then to go down
it's beautiful but the very next day
look at what happened what's happened
here is clouds and clouds have gotten in
the way of the Sun and indeed the clouds
interrupt the Sun so fast that in the
bottom part of the slide you can see
that it is even more variable than wind
power so even we looked at the
mathematical characterization of the
sunlight and found that it's going to be
more expensive to integrate solar power
at least from photovoltaic panels into
the grid than it is wind power so it's
those kind of things that we're learning
about the advanced electric power system
that we hope will take us into the grid
of the future and the opportunities for
our PhD students really do all the work
are fantastic they are going to have a
wonderful time over their lifetime in
this really exciting field